I can watch like a football game which I
recognize is ridiculous I understand I
certainly want that you're not watching
you're not sitting there watching the
commercials like that you get like
little brain breaks right so you get
like a two minutes of action and then
you can go be on your phone or do
whatever and then you're back
what Americans call soccer okay well
there are no commercials so I'm watching
is that what you were talking about when
you said football well no I was actually
talking about American football there
because I'm not thank God I got worried
for a second don't do that by the way
well I have to do it for the record it
used to be called soccer yeah I know I
know but they get angry Glenn I don't
know why they get so angry they're the
one who invented this I got a damn Sport
and called it soccer I understand okay I
understand I understand